>>> JOINING US IS SCARLETT LEWIS
HER SON JESSE LEWIS WAS KILLED
IN HIS FIRST GRADE CLASSROOM
DURING THE SHOOTING AT SANDY
HOOK.
SCARLETT FOUNDED THE JESSE LEWIS
CHOOSE LOVE MOMENT IN HONOR OF
HER SON.
SHE AND JESSE'S FATHER SPOKE AT
THE DEFINITION TRIAL LAST WEEK
AGAINST ALEX JONES AND WERE
AWARDED NEARLY $50 MILLION IN
SPENCE TORE AND PUNITIVE
DAMAGES.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
I KNOW YOU'VE GONE THROUGH WHAT
YOU'VE GONE THROUGH LAST WEEK
THE CULMINATION OF SO MUCH WORK
YOU'VE BEEN DOING FOR SO LONG.
I DO WANT TO ASK, ALEX JONES
HANDED YOU A NOTE INSIDE THAT
COURTROOM.
WHAT DID IT SAY?
>> HE DID.
ON THE LAST DAY BEFORE THE
PUNITIVE DAMAGES HE HANDED BOTH
NEIL AND I A NOTE AND IT
BASICALLY SAID THAT HE WAS VERY
TRULY SORRY AND THAT HE EXTENDED
AN OLIVE BRANCH AND WANTED TO
WORK WITH THE CHOOSE LOVE
MOVEMENT TO BRING MORE LOVE INTO
SCHOOLS, HOMES AND COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE WORLD.
>> DO YOU BUY IT?
>> WELL, I'M WAITING.
I HAVE HOPE.
>> YOU LOOKED INTO HIS EYE IN
THAT COURTROOM.
WHAT DID YOU SEE?
>> I SAW SOMETHING THAT I DIDN'T
EXPECT.
I SAW A VERY LONELY PERSON.
I SAW SOMEBODY WITH A HUGE VOID
AND I REALIZED THAT THAT WAS
WHERE THE LIES AND THE GREED
WERE ACTUALLY COMING FROM.
TO FILL THAT.
AND OF COURSE BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR NINE AND A HALF
YEARS, I KNOW THAT THE ONLY
THING THAT DOES FILL THAT VOID
IS LOVE AND THAT'S WHY I STARTED
THE CHOOSE LOVE MOVEMENT.
>> YOU SAID IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR
YOU TO DO THIS, TO BE THERE, TO
SPEAK OUT, TO LIVE UP TO JESSE'S
MODEL.
TALK TO ME ABOUT THAT.
>> WELL, JESSE IS KNOWN FOR
SAVING NINE OF HIS CLASSMATES'
LIVES BEFORE LOSING HIS OWN.
THE SHOOTER, A RECENT FORMER
GRADUATE OF NEW TOWN SCHOOL
SYSTEM, WENT BACK TO THE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL THAT HE HAD
ATTENDED WHERE HIS MOTHER HAD
TAUGHT, HE SHOT HIS WAY THROUGH
THE GLASS DOORS, MADE A LEFT
DOWN THE FIRST GRADE HALLWAY
THAT HE KNEW BECAUSE HE HAD
ATTENDED THERE.
THE PRINCIPAL AND GUIDANCE
COUNSELOR CAME OUT OF A MEETING
WITH A PARENT THAT THEY WERE
HAVING ON THE RIGHT-HAND SIDE,
HE KILLED THEM AND THEN TURNED
INTO JESSE'S CLASSROOM AND JESSE
STOOD UP TO HIM AND SAVED NINE
OF HIS CLASSMATES' LIVES.
SO, YOU KNOW, IN COMPARISON HE
WAS STANDING UP TO THE ULTIMATE
BULLY, SO I WAS ABLE TO DO THAT
WITH ALEX AND HAVING JESSE RIGHT
BEHIND ME.
>> STANDING UP TO BULLIES.
>> YES.
>> WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
ALEX JONES AS A BULLY, WHAT DOES
THAT REPRESENT IN OUR SOCIETY?
WHAT IS THIS BULLY THAT YOU SEE
IN HIM?
>> IT'S -- WELL, I MEAN, HE WAS
FOUND GUILTY OF SPREADING LIES
TO INTENTIONALLY HARM SOMEONE.
YOU KNOW, I WAS SITTING IN THE
COURTROOM THINKING TO MYSELF I
CAN'T BELIEVE THAT I'M HERE
ACTUALLY HAVING TO HOLD A GROWN
MAN ACCOUNTABLE FOR LYING AND
DOING THAT INTENTIONALLY.
WHEN I WAS SPEAKING TO THEM IN
THE COURTROOM IT WAS ALMOST LIKE
I WAS CHASTISING A YOUNG BOY.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT THIS
VERDICT WILL HELP KEEP THIS TYPE
OF BULLYING FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN?
>> I DO.
I THINK THAT THE VERDICT SENDS A
VERY STRONG MESSAGE.
IN FACT, MY ATTORNEY IN HIS
CLOSE ASKED THE JURY TO CHOOSE
LOVE OVER HATRED AND FEAR, AND
THEY DID, AND I THINK THAT THIS
SENDS A VERY STRONG MESSAGE FOR
TRUTH TO ALL OF US.
WE NEED TRUTH TO HAVE A CIVIL
SOCIETY AND TO HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS AND CONNECTIONS
WITH ONE ANOTHER.
>> AND I KNOW THE GOAL IS TO
HAVE THIS MONEY GO TO THE
FOUNDATION AND DO THE WORK TO
CHOOSE LOVE AND SPREAD LOVE.
DO YOU THINK YOU WILL EVER SEE
THAT MONEY, THOUGH, WITH ALL THE
SHENANIGANS THAT CAN HAPPEN FROM
HERE OUT?
>> I DO.
I DO.
I HAVE A LOT OF HOPE AND WE'RE
GOING TO PUT IT TO VERY GOOD USE
AND I THINK IT'S ALMOST ACTUALLY
POETIC JUSTICE THAT THAT WILL GO
TOWARDS KEEPING KIDS SAFE IN
SCHOOLS AND CHOOSING LOVE.
>> JESSE WOULD BE PROUD OF YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I THINK HE WOULD THINK YOU
ARE LIVING UP TO HIS EXAMPLE.
SCARLETT, THANKS FOR BEING WITH
US THIS MORNING.
>> THANK YOU.